تستضيف مدينه جده غربيه السعوديه مؤتمر
ومعرض خدمات الحج والعمره اكسبو الحج خلال
الفتره من التاسع الى الثاني عشر من يناير
الجاريه ومن المتوقع ان يشهد اكسبو الحاج
التوقيع 400 اتفاقيه وشراكه في ظل ما يحظى
به المؤتمر من اهتمام الدولي كبير وذلك
بمشاركه وجود دوليه من اكثر من سبع وخمسين
دوله تتناولوا جلسات المؤتمر عده موضوعات
من ابرازها خدامه خدمات النقل والاعاشه
للحجاج والفراسه الاستثماريه فضلا عن
اثراء تجربه ضيوف الرحمن الثقافيه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا نائب وزير الحج
والعمره الدكتور عبد الفتاح نشاط دكتور
عبد الفتاح اهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
او لما الجديد في في المؤتمر مؤتمر الحج
الدولي واكسبو الحج في نسخته الثانيه هذا
العام
النسخه الثانيه لمعرض ومعتمر الحج كل شيء
جديد
تحدثنا عن المجالات التي يغطيها المؤتمر
فهو مجالات كبيره جدا تغطي كامل رحله همم
الحاج من بدايه اصوله او قبل الوصوله الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حتى عوده مرورا
بجميع مراحل همم رحلته الاسرائيليه
والايمانيه اذا تحدثنا عن عدد المشاركين
العدل الكبير جدا ذكرت انه فعلا 57 او 58
دوله مشاركه من اصحاب المعالي رؤساء
ووزراء همم الجهات المختصه بالحج والاوقاف
في دينهم بل انه يتعدل العدد الى اكثر من
120 دوله ارسلوا مكاتب شلون الحاج لعقد
ال- ال- همم الاتفاقيات تحت القبه في خلال
الاربع ايام القادمه اذا تحدثنا عن عدد
المتحدثين عدد
كبير جدا متحدثين عن حياتك انك نتحدث عن
اكثر من 70 متحدث في 25 جلسه متخصصه وكل
ما هو موجود في معرض ومعتمر هذا هذه السنه
وفي النسخه الجديده لهذه السنه فيعتبر
جديد ولم يكن لوزاره الحج والعمره اي اي
همم
عمل بهذا الكبر وبهذا الحجم من التنوع من
العدد المشاركه ممكن تعطيني فكره عن
الاتفاقيات اللي راح تتوقع مع في تحت
القبه يعني الحديث عن اكثر من 400 اتفاقيه
هذا كبير كبيره
صحيح طبعا احنا اعتدنا في السنوات الماضيه
وقبل الجايحه ياتون مكاتب شون الحج لهم
القائمين وممثل الحجاج من جميع انحاء
العالم على مدار تقريبا شهرين لتوقيع
اتفاقيات مع
شركات والمؤسسات المتخصصه في تقديم
الخدمات اثناء الحج
قبه واحده في مؤتمر واحد وفي معرض واحد
يتم فيه استعراض كافه الخدمات من كل
الشركات المقدمه للخدمه وبالتالي سنقدم
منظومه متكامله وبالسلامه في نفس الوقت
تسهم في تطوير تجربه الضيوف الرحمن
والاستفاده من جميع الرؤى والافكار
المختصين واستشار المستقبل طبعا هيكون فيه
هناك حديثنا العديد من الاطروحات الجديده
والابداعيه لسيتم طرحها خلال هذه المؤتمر
وهذه فرصه حقيقه اللي مكاتب شؤون الحج
وممثلين الحجاج اللي همم
للاستعراضها والوقوف عليها مباشره والتاكد
منه هيجيء ثاني من الخدمه التي يطلبونها
يكون مقدم لهم في فتره الحج دكتور
نبحث كذلك على التنوع التنافسيه بين جميع
المقدمه
من هذا المؤتمر الى الطرح الموجود فيه من
المتحدثين من الجلسات التي تقام اعطينا
مثال يعني هو النسخه الثانيه فبالتالي في
النسخه الاولى على سبيل المثال كيف
استفدتوا من التوصيات او نتائج هذا الموسم
طبعا في كل في المؤتمر السابق الى يعني
اذا كان في السنه الماضيه كان هناك تقديم
بعض الافكار الابداعيه وهي تم استفاده
منها في موسم السنه الماضيه والاله الحمد
سجلت بعض الافكار حقيقه ردود فعل ايجابيه
هذه السنه من خلال التركيز على استخدام
تحديدا التقنيات همم تقنيه المستقبل
والتقنيات المبتكره همم اكيد هيكون فيها
اشراك للمبتدرين ورواد الاعمال وهذا كله
يعزز جوده الخدمات القدمه في الحج على قدر
ما نستطيع ان احنا في وزاره الحج والعمره
ايجاد بيئه ممكنا للقطاع الخاص والقطاع
غير الربحي همم التواجد ونشر ابداعاتهم
ابتكارات من خلال المعرض على قد ما حقيقه
انه يحقق اهداف المعرض وهي تجويد الخدمه
وفي نفس الوقت همم التنافسيه
همم جيده بين جميع اطراف مقدمه خدمه
والمستفيدي من الخدمه
مؤخراطلقت همم عمليه تسجيل حجاج الداخل
هذه لاول مره في هذا التوقيت بتوقيت مبكر
تقريبا قبل التوقيت المعتاد لاطلاق هذه
العمليه بالعاده في شوال اليوم تقريبا قبل
اربعه الى خمسه اشهر من هذا الموعد
المعتاد
الفائده يعني من الاطلاقه في هذا الوقت
المبكر
حقيقه انا استفدنا من التاجر وقت السنه
الماضيه السنه الماضيه كانت صحينا عدد
الحجاج مليون حاج لكن اعطنا حقيقه ناريه
بالعداد الجيد
للحج ولله الحمد سجلت معظم المؤشرات نجاح
كبير جدا بعد الحج مباشره بدانا الاستعداد
الحج الموسم القادم الى 1440 الان نحن
احييتنا نقطف ثمار
التنسيق المتكامل همم الجهود التنسيقيه
بين جميع القطاعات نحن نعلم جميعا 35 جهه
حكوميه وجهه عامه تعمل لخدمه الرحمن
التنسيق المبكر همم على مستوى ان كان على
المستوى الاستراتي لوضع الخطه
الاستراتيجيه بالاضافه الى الخطط
التنفيذيه هذه كلها سعادتنا عليه انه نحن
نبدا همم تنفيذ الخطتنا همم بشكل مبكر
طبعا يعني طرحنا للمناصه اكيد هيكون فيه
هناك معلومات يكون في تنوع همم كبير جدا
بطرح باقات همم الحج التواصل المبكر بين
مقدمه الخدمه وبين الحجاج هي كله اثر كبير
جدا حقيقي في همم الاستفاده من متطلباتهم
والوقوف عليها والتنفيذها بوقت مبكر هذه
كلها هتساعدنا على ان يكون الخدمه ان شاء
الله باذن الله ستقدم في فتره موسم القادم
باعلى مستوى وهذه احلى الاسباب اللي
جعلتني لان احنا منتهي من
استعدادا للحج وهذا ليس فقط على مستوى
حجاج الداخل ولكن حتى على مستوى حجاج
الخارجي
دكتور شكرا جزيلا لك على التواجد